okay so there's a reason why it's not
uncommon for audiophiles
to use Steely Dan records to test the
sound quality of new speakers the band
is among the most sonically
sophisticated pop acts of the 20th and
21st century not just in audio fidelity
but in the complexity of their jazz and
blues influenced songs today I want to
break down one of my favorite Steely Dan
songs Deacon blues to show you what goes
in to making one of these things and we
might as well back up and start at the
intro which I'll play again
so that is one of the most recognizable
intros in Steely Dan's whole discography
because it features a unique kind of
court that's become a defining feature
of their music it's called the MU major
court they called it that a specific
chord voicing that swaps a second-degree
note for a tonic note in a major chord
for example if you take the C major
chord C GCE
and you switch the second C for a D note
you've made a C mu major chord and you
can hear MU majors all throughout steely
dance music like in the first chorus of
black cow the chorus of don't take me
alive
even right here in their first album on
fire in the hole and it should be noted
that even though Steely Dan squeezed the
moon major for all it's worth
this voicing has a history that goes all
the way back to the 12th century the
first time it was ever used was in
parrot in the greats mid Arun Tom Ness
take a listen to the beautiful second
syllable of a mess right here
after these quintessential expressions
of the MU major chord the song dives
into the first verse and we begin to
hear the story of a suburban man in
crisis fantasizing about becoming an
alcoholic saxophone player
instrumentation includes a Rhodes piano
a bass that sort of floats along
carrying the rhythm Larry Carlton
steadily holding the melody on guitar
adding small frills which are hardly
noticeable but extremely important and
that they keep you from getting bored
with the progression while complementing
Fagin's vocals you have an acoustic
guitar in there too and the great
Bernard Purdie one of the best groove
drummers of all time
it's Porter
if you listen to Deacon blues on great
headphones or speakers you hear just how
good this music sounds every instrument
has its own life each sound is thick and
close-up when it needs to be to achieve
this
Fagen and Becker were explicit and
following the example of legendary jazz
producer and engineer Rudy Van Gelder
whose work at Blue Note Records defined
a generation of jazz music Van Gelder
was notoriously secretive about his
techniques but it's known that he had
musicians play very close to the
microphones to make his instrument sound
warm and intimate
anyone who's used microphones like the
one I'm recording this narration on
right now knows that every microphone
has a different quality of sound Steely
Dan's producer Roger Nicol described his
extensive microphone collection in an
interview once and the point is that the
band experimented exhaustively to get
just the right sound for each instrument
and vocal you can hear right there that
when we enter the second verse of Deacon
blues a horn section comes in composed
by Tom Scott who detailed in a
Washington Post interview how he modeled
his horns after Oliver Nelson's
orchestral style in which middle
register horns slide against one another
to create a thicker dissonant sound
you
Fagin insisted Scott include nothing in
the high end and for this reason when
the bridge comes and the saxophone solo
happens personifying the main character
of the song it cuts through the mix like
a lightning
because of the saxophone solo is such an
important part of the song Fagen and
Becker searched for the right player to
embody the sound one night they turned
on The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
and saw this that's pink chrisley thick
platinum earned a worker saxophone play
what I feel free Scotch whisky all night
long and died behind the wheel and I
thought it were talking about my life so
you're misusing I just had to take my
one take
the instrumentation on deacon booze is
immaculate and complex but i think the
lyrics are just as important Deacon
blues tells the story of a midlife
crisis a man living a safe life in
suburbia looking through the glass at
gamblers and wild Ramblers seeing
romance in the million lights of the
city at night he wants to be a
saxophonist drink scotch whiskey and die
behind the wheels Deacon blues is a song
of existential desire a desire as Becker
says for one of those mythic forms of
loserdom and opposite to the routine
middle register existence that stretches
life to a thin film of small
significance
Fagen and Becker have always been
sardonic and wry songwriters they're
smooth jazzy feel stands and direct
almost mocking opposition to the punk
rock sound that was gaining popularity
at the same time there's always a
detachment in their songs and
uncertainty about exactly who they're
making fun of for example they came up
with the name of the song Deacon blues
by recognizing how ridiculous it was to
give sports teams majestic nicknames
like University of Alabama's Crimson
Tide this mocking tone has turned a lot
of people off to their music but Deacon
blues I think contains a hidden
earnestness in the lead into the first
chorus the narrator says he's ready to
cross that fine line the line between
his existence and the one he wants to
have the song suggests that he's tried
before and failed but the music plays
these lines like he's taking a running
head start barreling toward a chorus
that explodes into the fantasy fully
realized
I just what I feel
for this reason I think you can look at
deakin Blues as a kind of literature the
story seems to be the central component
here with each element of the music
filling out nuances in the main
characters fantasy to the point where
it's unclear in the last verse whether
the narrator has actually done it or has
just been caught up in the dream
I think listening to Steely Dan with
some good headphones rewards close
readings like this the layers are all
there for you to examine one by one or
simply enjoy in their combined
expression the quality is great the
composition is complex and the lyrics
are interesting and dense for me all of
that adds up to a song that is going to
last
I wanna name
they come
Oh
hey everybody thanks for watching I love
Steely Dan and I love this because I've
never analyzed a song before and I love
trying new things special thanks to the
Washington Post and to Howard Wright's
work on the MU major chord and Steely
Dan such comprehensive stuff there from
both those guys I link them below I want
to give them a special thanks I want to
tell you guys about a channel that I
really love it's called wisecrack you
can see it right there they do video
essays like me and we've been pushing to
each other because I think if you like
my stuff you're definitely like theirs
they do thug notes earthling cinema
8-bit philosophy there's really great
funny work so click over there watch one
subscribe I know you guys are going to
love it I have to catch a plane right
now to Pennsylvania because I'm about to
give my first TED talk excited and
nervous and I'll see you guys on the
other side